but first a look at a man whose
allegations have been
shaking turkish politics siddhart peka
a convicted organized crime boss now
living in exile in dubai
has been dishing the dirt on members of
president recep tayyip erdogan's ruling
party
in recent weeks he's published a series
of tell-all videos that have captivated
the nation and
turned him into an unlikely social media
phenomenon
this fugitive boss has become a youtube
sensation in turkey
his videos make damaging claims about
top
turkish politicians
you will be defeated by a camera and a
tripod
i swear you will be defeated
pecker's allegations range from drug
trafficking and rape
to murder and arms dealing his videos
have been viewed over 100 million times
i wait with such excitement every week
for a new episode
just like with my favorite tv shows we
get up and watch the videos at breakfast
many of his claims are already known but
when he talks and provides
evidence people wake up people want to
see the truth
it's almost like a tv drama and all of
us are waiting for the season finale
is a well-known turkish underworld
figure
he's been in and out of prison for a
string of crimes that span three decades
from extortion to running a criminal
organization
picker once fervently supported
president erdogan's ruling coalition
but fled turkey in late 2019. he now
lives in the united arab emirates
people listen to him because the media
here in turkey has been silenced
they can't report many facts so people
prefer to believe what a mafia leader
says
that's very tragic actually
pekka's main target has been interior
minister suleiman soilo
whom he accuses of corruption and of
betraying him
you will be taken to the highest court
you will be tried and punished
you have no chance i will reveal
everything i will destroy you step by
step
i have the evidence i will take you down
all those implicated by pekka have
rejected his accusations
the ruling akp and their allies have
also blocked parliamentary inquiries
into the claims
president erdogan has weighed in
personally
dismissing pekka's allegations as an
attack on turkey
with god's help and the support of the
people we will foil this conspiracy
no one should doubt that we will disrupt
this insidious plot
pekka promised to make erdogan the focus
of future videos
but his weekly revelations have stopped
in his latest video he says his life is
at risk
i'm on a red list which means there's a
high risk of me being assassinated
but i will keep my promise to you god
willing we will have a lot of fun in the
coming days
i will drive them all insane
[Music]
it's hard to predict what will happen
but the fact that he told his viewers
don't worry despite the risk of being
killed i will continue to reveal what i
know
means that he will not give up easily
pekka has not yet
provided concrete evidence for his
gangster stories
but according to polls a majority of his
viewers believe
that there is at least some truth to his
allegations
and many are eagerly waiting for the
next episode
of his mafia drama
you